good morning Hank it's Tuesday I've said
those words on video something like 1,00
times in the last 17 years and you've
said good morning John even more often
because you've taken fewer vacations but
just to State the obvious uh I'm not
always going to be saying good morning
Hank it's Tuesday because everything
ends or at least everything that we've
observed seems to end I'm going to look
at this through two metaphorical lenses
that of the professional athlete but
first that of the television show most
TV shows last for like one or two
seasons gr's Anatomy has been around for
19 years years making it about a year
and a half older than Vlog Brothers Law
and Order SVU has been on the air for 25
years but those are exceptions even very
successful shows often don't last that
long friends lasted 10 seasons the
office 9 The West Wing 8 everything ends
and not only that I would argue
everything should end so there's been a
lot of attention on YouTuber retirements
this year which I think is basically
good news like in a very new medium we
need to figure out how people people say
goodbye or at least how they say goodbye
to this or how they say goodbye for a
while but Hank you and I've been on
YouTube long enough to know this isn't
exactly new like most successful
creators of their moment move on from
making YouTube videos in fact of the
crop of featured creators at the first
ever VidCon in 2010 almost none of them
today make their living on YouTube
people move on from the platform to
other opportunities or their audiences
shrink to the point where it's no longer
fulfilling to make vide or whatever else
things end and having a show that runs
for seven or eight seasons is not some
failure or tragedy it's a tremendous
success in the comments of Tom Scott's
last video I wrote congrats Tom and a
lot of people replied why would you
congratulate him on stopping making
videos I guess I wanted to congratulate
him because of course it was a carefully
considered decision and the right
decision for him but also because he
finished he finished his run of 10 years
of weekly videos he completed the
project and this brings me to my second
metaphor professional Athletics so most
pro athletes play between 1 and Four
Seasons before retiring a few get 10
very few end up like Tom Brady playing
for 23 Seasons Hank in this metaphor you
and I are in that lucky few who are able
to hang around for many years in the
league but of course just to State the
obvious we are not Tom Brady Mr Beast is
Tom Brady and I wish him so much luck
with that it seems like a very very
stressful job we are like second string
offensive linemen who are kind of
personality hires like we're good in the
locker room and so we're allowed to hang
around but we've managed to stay in the
league since 2007 which is amazing and
most amazing of all we still love it
here I do think a lot about how Vlog
Brothers will end I mean maybe it will
end in death and I guess I would be okay
with that if this became like an archive
of what two people were thinking and
experiencing while they were both here
that said I'm not convinced that Vlog
Brothers ideal ending would would be
death I think the ideal ending is that
like Tom Scott we complete the project I
just don't know exactly what completing
the project looks like I used to think
it looked like finishing Brotherhood 2.0
on December 31st 2007 I used to think
that it looked like finishing the
maternal Center of Excellence but I
didn't feel finished on December 31st
2007 and frankly I don't feel finished
now because I do think and worry about
this a lot I I talk with my friends a
lot about it and I have a friend who's a
recently retired professional athlete
and so I asked him like how did you know
it was time and he told me the game
tells you when you're done I love the
game so much and I respect it and it
told me when I was done Hank we're in
our 18th season of Vlog brothers and I
would be lying if I told you I thought
this was the first half of the project
but I love this YouTube game I respect
it and it hasn't told me I'm done yet it
seems to me like the game still has a
use for us so I'll see you on
Friday